going back real quickly 1984 you said it
was a book that you would be one of the
five books that you would take with you
if you couldn't read any other books I
was just curious why 1984 I want to get
in trouble for this but in 1984
something worth living today you're
durable it's my favorite books at the
time but I've been reading looking at
the film and reading the book since its
last election and it has a section about
the thought police
you guys ever read that Medina for I
know parts of it I haven't read it by
George where well yes but I've heard the
whole concept about what the thought
police
but the thought police in 1984 I mean
you're not allowed to do anything
without the permission of the police and
they determine your reality they create
this war that's not looking at what is
happening at all but they have these
soldiers marching and all this stuff and
blah blah blah blah that you're not
allowed to have a relationship without
their permission
can't just fall in love yet to have it
let me go through them so Richard Burton
is the head of the thought police and
John great actor John forget his name he
is a citizen and he miss young girl fall
in love they kept meeting secretly at
his place in her placing and running
away and running one day that I thought
caught but I thought police in the
helicopters coming the soldiers come in
and kept available and take them to the
thought police headquarters and
John the actor forgot his name was lying
on the table I thought police
headquarters and there's a spotlight on
the table he's lying there naked with
his hands tied and his feet tied and
symmetrical force I'm suited to the
table with a switch that if you turn the
switch on it just electrocute you
and there's water coming down so it's a
guy near the button in Richard Burton is
sitting there in Javas I'm so sorry I
was wrong I did I said I did the wrong
thing I'm apologizing never should have
ever ever ever seen her and then an
image of Brittany says well you know she
said that you started it he said well I
don't I don't know I just he says okay
and he says I'll never do it again
please forgive me free just when I trust
so he says to Jesus how many things am i
holding up John says for Roberta nos at
a guy with the button sure Jeff oh
what'd I do wrong what do they what's
wrong
how many fingers am i holding up for oh
what'd I do wrong
how many fingers am i holding up
I don't know I don't know better how
many fingers am i holding up
three three
I'm holding up as many fingers because I
tell you yes I'm holding up
you got nothing dude your eyes nothing
dude your intellect or your mind
I say it's three fingers how many are
they three three alternative fact is in
three an alternate effect you won't
believe what we tell him to believe
nothing to do with your perspective at
all okay not me
you